[Music]  kicking off et's Kardashian ketchup Kris  and Kendall's a mother-daughter date  night  the Jenner's were on hand for the  Harper's Bazaar 150th anniversary event  in NYC where Kendall's face was  projected onto the Empire State Building  just be cool  also stepping out on Wednesday Rob  Kardashian and blac Chyna the back on  couple enjoyed dinner at Asian eatery  Tao in Hollywood China rocking a purple  wig for the fun night out the star even  shared this sweet snap holding hands  with her man we're all in a good place  and here is your first look at Sunday  night's episode of Keeping Up with the  Kardashians Kris furious with how ex  Caitlyn Jenner portrays her in her new  memoir  I'm not gonna be used as a person who  benefits someone else's life just to  make them look better I just can't sit  back and be an enabler anymore I've  never been so angry and disappointed in  somebody in my whole life I'm done